après l'as st s voici que la régie
présente aujourd'hui la renault 6
l'apparenté de ligne est évidente les
deux modèles appartenant à la catégorie
des berlines transformable la nouvelle
voiture a été conçue à partir d'une
plateforme de renault 4 c'est aussi une
traction avant mais le moteur est celui
de deauville gordini de cinq chevaux
fiscaux pour 34 réel
le prix est de 7 1990 francs avec
banquettes et de 8290 avec si elle
avançait paris inclinable comme ici le
tableau de bord est ornée de plastique
imitant le bois et les touches de
commandes sont en retrait on voit d'ici
les manettes de commandes de
climatisation et de chauffage
puis le levier de vitesses identiques en
tous points celui de la renault 4 comme
sur la renault 16 les phares sont
réglables en fonction de l'assiette de
la voiture à l'arrière la banquette
repliable procure un très grand volume
de chargement
c'est sur les belles routes du
languedoc-roussillon que nous avons
d'abord essayé la renault 6 plus large
que la r4 il est très confortable et
dispose de quatre glaces descendante
quant à la vitesse et des très
raisonnable puisqu'elle est de l'ordre
de 120 kilomètres heure mais n'at-on pas
dit que l'automobile était un instrument
d'évasion et roulante en solitaire nous
avons découvert des routes poétique aux
beautés inconnu révéler ici par les
images d'europe pescadère puis nous
avons attaqué les pentes des cévennes
dont les routes sinueuses ont mis en
valeur la suspension à grand débattement
et la tenue de route hérité des renault
4 et 16
voici le passage dans un lacet
la voiture grimpe avec vaillance et on
le voit elle prend très bien les virages
serrés
voici maintenant la descente dans le
cirque impressionnant de navacelles
avant la fin de notre essai
[Musique]